you are free now my sister free and safe
we've might be what I've been made to do
I know about the mortal if you hadn't
got me out that would be me in there we
need to help
[Music]
you come in you have no idea what a
relief that is
[Music]
Thank You Missy buckle
just heard from again
all League and team raids were
successful rescue teams from every
granny trafficking Depot are safe at the
Taos meta-human Youth Center
congratulate yourselves meta human
trafficking has been dealt a major blow
tonight there's more news
violets permanently cleanse me of father
box his influence you're sure yeah I can
feel the difference so can i princess
Tara please I am no princess anymore
that's my fault
no doctor I am well aware my uncle
threatened to kill me if you didn't
activate my meta chain and I am also
aware that you're the only person who
was kind to me during that time
then you can forgive me if I can be
forgiven my sins how can I not forgive
other stairs and you say you're no
longer a princess Tara I want you to
meet violet Harper my girlfriend
girlfriend why don't we go inside and
let the kids get better acquainted
Oh Connor before you go in baganz gonna
kill me
I'm not sure what to do with Vic but geo
force Tara halo and forger maybe just
maybe they might be ready for the team
[Music]
everybody is Charlie they finally aired
the Young Justice finale for the first
half of the season there will be a
second half of the season so I'll
explain what's going on but we just got
a tee up for the next big arc and it's
going to be based on Teen Titans the
Judas contract so we have to break it
down if you're new to the channel I'm
doing Young Justice videos and DC
Universe videos be sure to subscribe to
get everything Doom Patrol is the next
big TV show I'll remind people about the
schedule at the end of the video too and
when the second half of The Young
Justice episodes are gonna air this year
so don't worry you're not gonna have to
wait that long to get the rest of the
Young Justice season three it's like the
next big story arc so starting with that
end scene Deathstroke secretly plants
Terra Markov Terra from the Teen Titans
comics inside Nightwing and Miss
Martian's young justice team as a teaser
for their next big story arc which is
going to be young justices version of
Teen Titans the Judas contract if you
haven't read the comics or you didn't
see the animated at Teen Titans Judas
contract movie that DC released last
year that's where Tara pretends to be
their friend and teammate going on
missions and in this Young Justice
version of that storyline trying to take
down the light the League of Shadows the
reach any of their evil sub groups who
are members of the light but secretly
it's all part of Deathstroke's plan to
destroy the Young Justice team from
within they could either have Tara
eventually help capture her teammates
while they're inside one of the lights
secret bases or maybe she helps destro
kidnap some of them a couple at a time I
don't know if they're gonna do the Beast
Boy terrible lationship because Beast
Boy had his big arc in this last couple
of episodes they explained where he's
been I'll talk about him in a second
because he's kind of teasing a different
story thread and they use him to address
a lot of wally west stuff and try to
make you cry as much as possible so
there was a lot of good beast boy stuff
in these final episodes to the original
Teen Titans Judas contract storyline is
very different like they don't have a
Teen Titans team on Young Justice so
it's like the Nightwing Miss Martian
team in place of the Teen Titans but
this is a clip of that animated movie of
Terra's turn in Deathstroke's plan
you're so freakin annoying you don't
know anything about him
he saved me let me guess he kept you
isolated dependent told you everyone was
your enemy trained you ruthlessly
and promised you exactly what you wanted
believe me I know I've always hated you
you and all the others treated you like
family
you threw it all away there are a couple
things from that storyline that I don't
think that they're gonna do like Tara in
the comics had a relationship with
Deathstroke obviously that's the
creepiest thing ever and this version of
Tara is way younger than comic book Tara
so I don't think they're gonna do
anything like that maybe in this version
he'll be like her twisted surrogate
father manipulating her without her
really realizing it so she feels like
more of a victim we can talk more about
that when we get the second half of the
episodes we actually see what its gonna
look like but the main arc of the first
half of this season this first block of
13 episodes was taking down the Med
human trafficking ring in finding and
rescuing Tara so that's how they book in
the season yay we found her we
dismantled most of their metahuman
trafficking on earth and we brought her
back but surprised twist it was all part
of Deathstroke's plan to allow them to
do this
so what lets you know what a badass
Deathstroke is that he was able to play
Batman and all these other people and
how long he's been planning this because
in one of the earlier episodes Batman
and his team infiltrate the island where
Deathstroke was keeping the League of
Shadows
he's the new demons head we don't know
how that happened because in an even
earlier episode racial Ghul says I'm no
longer the demon said I'm not leading
the League of Shadows but he won't say
who is and he doesn't offer any
explanation for how Deathstroke took
them from him if it was some sort of
fight or something else went on within
the light but while Batman and his team
are trying to infiltrate the island they
surveilled Deathstroke from afar who's
talking to Lady Shiva and vandal
savage's daughter who their training is
another member of the League of Shadows
he hears vandal savage's daughter ask
where Tara went because apparently they
knew each other within their training
and destro says that she washed out and
she's disappointed like maybe they had
some sort of relationship within the
League of Shadows or something like that
so Yuri watch that scene after this turn
after the reveal and it lets you know
the Deathstroke was aware that Batman
was watching him the whole time which is
totally badass
knew that Batman and his team would go
back and tell Nightwing in the Young
Justice people they would mount a rescue
mission
then Deathstroke would arrange for Tara
to quote-unquote
escape the men human trafficking ring
and that would plant her on the team so
they would think that it was all their
planned the whole time
we'll find her we'll rescue her it'll be
great but it's all part of his intricate
evil plan to tear them down from within
Thea the big WTF storyline was the
origin story for The Young Justice
version of cyborg it's a little
different from the comic book version
from the Justice League movie versions
but essentially it hits all the same
beats in this version of things he's a
little bit younger he's a high school
football player not a college football
player his father's still at STAR Labs
but he's experimenting on one of
Darkseid's father boxes instead of a
mother box for the Justice League and
the accident happens in the father box
is what Bond's to him and turns him into
cyborg the new gods of New Genesis hi
father
Orion the good people they're the ones
that create the mother boxes so mother
box is good father boxes evil that's why
cyborg freaks out on everyone but they
also use this storyline to reveal that
it's the living spirit of a dead mother
box that's bonded with halo and that
explains what all of our powers come
from and all this ancient knowledge that
she doesn't really know that she has she
can fly she can bring people back to
life from most deadly wounds she can
heal pretty much anything she can
project energy blast she can form
shields now we know that she can open
boom tubes she can basically do anything
that a mother box can do and even though
it's subconscious for her she has this
ancient warehouse of knowledge stuck in
her head so she could communicate with
ship and other new gods technology like
the stuff that's embedded now in cyborgs
the Beast Boy storyline was also super
messed up but they use it to explain
where he been during this big two-year
time jump what's going on with this
funny parody sci-fi TV show that he's
been doing and they use it to explain
what's going on with granny goodness
--is evil vr goggles that we all knew
we're going to be evil but now we know
exactly what they're being used for so
what I might do is a separate video for
all the Wally West's crazy mind space
stuff during the Beast Boy scenes just
because it was really cool and it tees
up some really cool stuff for the back
half of the season they'll continue
to do Wally West stuff on the TV show
big explainer for when the rest of the
episodes are coming and the rest of the
schedule for this year so second half of
season three the second block of 13
episodes will air at the beginning of
June right after the Doom Patrol finale
because Doom Patrol is starting February
15th which is just a couple weeks away
what'll happen is is the Super Bowl is
coming up there'll be a crazy number of
comic book trailers during the Superbowl
for Avengers endgame and probably for
some other stuff but otherwise things
will be pretty normal click here for all
my Young Justice
season 3 videos and click here for my
brand new spider-man far from home
sinister six video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]